before this video begins I just wanted
to let you guys know as I announced on
Instagram a few days ago our dog Maya
sadly passed away and uh this video was
filmed in November so she's still in
this video
um usually we like to announce you know
fun stuff in the blog
so we kind of keep it a secret in this
Vlog in particular there is a big
announcement yeah the timing is just
weird the fact that this video got so
delayed
it doesn't help she's been taking part
in videos for as long as his channel has
existed so I I feel like it was only
fair to let you guys know and I also
really appreciate and want to say thank
you for all the love and support these
past couple days
uh to me Marcia and Maya and
I really appreciate it enjoy the Vlog
happy Halloween
I might say I cooked something very
special check this out damn so aesthetic
with a light
this is spinach pumpkin
gnocchi yeah
let me try the pumpkin
um pumpkin is good
it's so nice huh
it's almost November
you can sit outside and it's still
really nice and warm
love that big fan of that usually in
Sweden it snows around this time so it's
nice I'm studying mine says reading
eggy comes to me at reuning and he looks
at me are you looking for
trouble
oh yes
you know what time it is it's G fuel
time
check this out new cup plumbers yeah
looks so good
the cup of grease
very excited to announce G fuel has a
new flavor coming out two things I love
G fuel Gundam so I'm very excited to
announce the new Jeep fuel collab with
Gundam how sick is that do you feel just
killing it with a collapse and the
flavor fits perfectly it's ruminate
melon Ramen is an old Japanese drink it
dates back to 1884. it's an amazing
flavor and I love melon drinks so I'm so
excited for this flavor and I'm so
excited for this collab and if you guys
want to pre-order it it will ship next
month
and you'll get 30 off if you use the
code PewDiePie as much as I love my
chest cup the collector edition contains
a full rant stainless steel keep it nice
and cold I always prefer drinking out of
cans because it's so much colder use the
code PewDiePie as always you get 30 off
the next 48 hours so don't hesitate link
is in the description that's supposed to
be
where the house has been but I just look
like Jeffrey Dahmer
there's that devil in the corner we set
up like a trick-or-treat thing and a lot
of kids are coming we're actually
running low I can hear it I can hear
people outside I didn't think anyone
would come this one oh there we go
[Music]
thank you
Iggy you want to show everyone your
outfit Kawaii
he looks like a seal when he covers his
ears
everyone's so nice so far
we've been uh gifts she
oh
you open that
oh wow they are so cute check out the
cutest little demon
it's me and one other person in the
finale
he thinks I'm just chilling
but little does he know what I'm about
to do
foreign
oh you poor thing
you Baka yeah boy
look at that
look at all this stuff I got
morning
going surfing today
I'm picking up Chris
it's gonna be great I'm very excited
although it's very cold
we're kind of pushing this surfing thing
it's so fun though I love it it's so uh
challenging but I also like that it's a
seasonal thing but uh we'll see how long
we'll keep doing it but
depends how cold the water is today
all right
[Music]
check how fast my is
17.
Speedy Gonzalez
what's the secret sauce my is it the G
fuel
[Music]
what are we angry about in here
is it that people haven't subscribed to
the channel and click like yeah I know
they haven't quite liked either
what else should they do buy all the G
fuel
yeah I agree
I want to say it's uh climbing Mount a
cow with their friends I'm taking care
of the little ones
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yesterday's surf was so good
so fun I need to practice to go down the
line when I take off I keep forgetting
I'm like these ones are just so fun to
just ride it doesn't show on camera but
it felt huge like I felt like you come
in the way we're like
I've never seen waves that big it was so
fun damn I love I love surfing
being in the water in November is crazy
it was still warm
it's very meditative I think you're not
thinking about anything else when you're
doing it I really love it
tracking all my sessions
which is fun because then you can kind
of
see your progress
maybe I'll make a video on it someday
very different energies here we got Maya
and this devil eggy wanted me to show
you guys how strong he is a kill or the
haters or the evil comments
[Music]
I'm wearing a t-shirt it's amazing and
we're in the park leaves are falling
late
do you want some land
and give corns gracious as always get
out of here it's not yours
oh
look at that I love the virgin oil
I might send me these but what's the
secret flavor
you put tuna
thank you match made in heaven I can't
believe I feel like I'm shoving it in
you guys faces but the weather is so
nice November
it's warm and we are going Christmas
shopping
mice is going away so we have to do it a
bit early but hey at least at least we
don't do it before Halloween
this looks horrendous but my student
wants it look at that what his soul is
Animal Crossing fishing
Japanese rail simulator
that's so weird
my God
so I saw people did this where they see
how many treats they can give their dog
before they realize is is not a treat
I want to try it again
that was good there's another one
love it okay here's another one mmm
they're having a good time
something
okay
all right getting suspicious
okay
[Music]
all right here you go
[Laughter]
sorry I played you like a fool
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
director's view which shoots both
cameras front and back at the same time
hopefully it won't be too annoying for
Mars here to edit
we're in yoyogi park
and it's a very
what's the season it's full volumes I
love it so pretty though
so that's what I see and you guys see me
as well
this is so cool
why have I not used this before I saw a
random comment saying like
usually the youth director's view your
phone has it I'm like no he doesn't what
the [ __ ]
you can get beer in the park
that's pretty nice didn't know you were
allowed to
[Music]
um
that's oh that was good
[Music]
oh
my God how did we end up here
Sheboygan Crossing
God damn you Google Maps
[Music]
down the thick
I think his first time to meet his new
family member
you're excited again
[Music]
are you scaring me
thank you
oh thank you so much
oh you're so happy yeah
laughs
hey
[Music]
what are you doing right now hmm
what's the plan
um
she was playing with my hand
s for so long and then she looked up and
saw me she was like what you were here
and you liked it get up close huh
what is this move
you can link my hair but if you bite it
I'm gonna not like that
[Music]
yes
well done
[Music]
one
two
three I'm the king of pugs
looking good
Swedish pancakes know your peer European
no thick American
sweets
no no
it's okay
filming here
and you do something
okay so how do you make
thank you again it's perfect now
well then
you're welcome
forgot the most important thing
foreign
looks so aesthetic look at that none of
this get this out of the way
it's time to try it
very chewing
why is it so chewy
it's good though are you looking for
trouble
laughs
[Music]
I was working out
small earthquake hit
oh
I put like the earthquake tape
I don't know how the [ __ ] you made it
God damn Maya couldn't care less
[Music]
good morning gamers
beautiful day it's only 13 degrees now
but we're going surfing
one last time this will be the last of
the Season we're really [ __ ]
stretching it bring I'm going with Joey
he's never surfed before so
we get to go one last time I'm excited
for it
such a nice day
good surf you survived Joey
[Music]
how do you feel
what very soul
[Music]
you did good yeah that was fun I want to
do it again let's do it this is the last
surf of the season
next year
I'll be in bed yeah
[Music]
what a cutie
look at her
[Music]
you got your favorite egg here bow
that was a deep mouth
he's a good boy
me and eggy are getting some planks to
build for Mama
so she doesn't
climb up stuff
thank you foreign
[Music]
we're about to enter this sea of people
holy [ __ ]
oh my God
the line continues
all the way
so cool
very cool building I wonder if the line
will just go forever
we made it in
got the ticket
someone almost ran into Mars again
what it's all day
[Music]
cute
we got knives
there's such a
insane amount of stuff it's all like
handmade crafts though
but it's a lot to take in
it's gonna be
this is uh interesting we're getting
some long potato yeah God it's so hot
now I'm boiling out here we shank that
one side of one floor
yeah
let's check out this thing
hug mermaid
anyone
I have a feeling you're gonna buy
everyone
plant
that was sensory overload
there's just so much stuff I'm so tired
of walking too everyone everything
everyone's so talented but it was always
like I'll be something else but if
you've seen it anywhere else you'd be
like oh my God
oh
we're having so much fun over here guys
all right where the party
what was that I never heard that
and you cannot be defeated by this tiny
little rat
nice
[Music]
wearing something
Joey took me to the driving range and
this one's so sick look at this
there he is warming up
looking good
this is so cool
insane this puts my driving range to
shame I'm gonna hit the 300 one okay
no are you gonna go through well not
[Music]
all right
[Music]
Samosa has been away so I've been just
chilling on my own
and I spend the day in the arcade so
good
my shoulders are sore because I can't
like staying in this position people are
looking at me like what the [ __ ] am I
doing
I'm gonna get some food
then I'm heading back to the puggies
[Music]
thank you
what's going on here